come on
[Music]
yeah
drop it drop it drop it okay
[Applause]
suspect is a black guy
[Music]
it's the black guy
right here okay
[Music]
you gotta go you fine you gotta Grace
what's going on where's the suspect what
do they look like what do they look like
do they have a weapon does he have a
weapon he has a knife all right he's got
a shot he's been shot around the corner
is he still active is he moving step
beside me I'm step attack
drop the knife drop the knife drop the
knife back up back up
we're going to go there go over there my
neighbor okay now we're going we're
going black guys
who's got a gun sir don't move
I don't know I don't know I don't know
is he okay
check me check me I feel like I've been
here
are we good are we good everybody good I
don't know I don't know
okay
[Applause]
sit down sit down
shots fired
I'll cover you
come back
don't move man get your hands up don't
move just get your hands show me your
hands
show me your hands
hey
so right now gray shirt are you hurt
show me both your hands
again don't move
in and out injury
[Music]
the revolvers right there
right now yeah